Greg Anthony Turner Sports NBA analyst
about the game it's on at 9:00 Eastern
Time tonight on TNT how are you Greg I'm
doing a rich doing great how are you I
am well what happens tonight sir best
you can tell I don't know it cleared the
dollar yet I haven't heard that
obviously his absence really diminishes
their death Golden State and I do think
they were fatigued and that gate because
of the style and not having the bodies
and the thing about every dollar it's
like losing two guys because of his
versatility again having said all of
that they still got for all NBA guys and
nobody else in the league has four and
you should be able to win a game like
that at home when you hold the opponent
294 points so but but give the Rockets a
ton of credit for not giving up
believing that they can come back and
win I kind of give the Rockets a slight
edge tonight but you know let's see how
they handle success nobody's won two in
a row yet in this series you know can
they come out with the intensity they're
going to need because they're gonna face
a desperate Golden State team I don't
think there's any question about it and
the Golden State has proven through the
years that when they didn't desperate
for the most part they've been really
good so I do think it's gonna be a tough
game I think we might see something
similar to what we saw a game for and a
really competitive one down to the it
Greg Anthony Turner Sports here on the
Rich Eisen show it's a game time
decision for Iguodala is it like the NFL
where they're just gonna hide it even if
they already know it all the way to the
end because if you might make a
difference or not really you know what I
probably will prepare as if he's playing
you almost have to mentally you know you
want to be expecting that they're going
to be full strength that he's going to
be out there and he and a game plan box
and some because he's such a versatile
defender you know here's agarikon in
terms of how Houston is built he can
guard all five positions much like
draymond Green can so that versatility
gives them
a huge advantage and obviously not
having them out there will hurt Golden
State plus his decision-making uh pencil
he can make it open three he's an
excellent passer you know he's really
good in the open floor so it he'll be
missed there's no doubt about it because
those that bench you know and I talked
about this before the playoff start that
was the one concern I'd always had about
Golden State you know because their
roster was such now that they were going
to be reliant upon guys that they really
hadn't a lot of on before you know Nick
Young there
JaVale McGee played for him a lot
earlier you know they haven't been able
to use David less much in this series
Kevin Looney you know jordo these are
guys that hadn't necessarily proved
themselves on this stage and now not
only are they going to be played but
they're going to play they're gonna have
to play well you've gone in a hostile
territory United Houston two against a
team that I think will get a confidence
boost for having won that game the way
day one you start off down 1202 Golden
State you down 12 with 10:40 to go in
the fourth on the road and you're able
to come back and win that game that that
is it's about a resilient a game as I've
seen in Rockets play all season
yeah and it's not just that Greg it's
the way that they were down 12 in the
fourth quarter it's the barrage of
threes by by curry
I mean curry is just directly plugged
into that Oracle crowd it seems when
those things happen and it's so tough to
come back from or stop the question I
have is based on what you said the
Rockets have made the warriors certainly
without egg Wadala looked top-heavy in a
way and the question is I have is what
are the Rockets we'll have they been
able to do that other teams have not
really been able to do it against the
Durant warriors Greg well I think the
biggest thing they're able to do is
because of their ability to squish 1
through 5 and remember this is a
defensive oriented team and it's hard to
it sounds like an oxymoron with James
Harden on the roster right but it really
is if you think about Ariza and Bob lute
a PJ Tucker
Chris Paul Clint capela these are
defensive oriented players and so what
it's allowed them to do is to never have
to break down defensively all that
switching now you're going to catch
this matches if your golden state we've
seen that with Durant on Paul but if you
look at the numbers they are they're
triple the ISO plays now Golden State
then they had been over the course of
the postseason and regular sees they're
running three times as many which means
when they're doing that while that guy
can have success it makes you easier to
guard because I'm not getting cut up I'm
not getting back doored as much I'm able
to keep bodies on bodies it allows us to
basically load our defense control our
defensive backboard and if they do a
good job at home which I think they'll
be better than on the road we get out in
transition and so that's the big thing
they they're going to switch throughout
they can slow the game down with that
you know if they're not turning it over
it makes gold state have to play a
little later in the shot clock and it's
been affected and I think part of it
also is because they're able to really
be Steph Curry up on offense you know
they're able to basically continue to
put bodies on him and pick and rolls and
attack him one-on-one and if you notice
they don't bail them out with a lot of
jump shots they're always trying to keep
a body on them driving to the rim
forcing help or trying to finish and I
don't care who you are it takes a toll
it physically takes a toll to be in that
many possessions I saw why defensively
and then they have to go try and run and
be a part of the offense on the other
end so it's a really good strategy but
you also have to have the personnel to
execute it and remember their two best
ISO players are point guards Harden and
Paul so they're gonna you know they're
not uncomfortable but what they're being
asked to do by Mike D'Antoni and it's
one reason why they have at least a
chance in this series and this game boy
is going to be like a game 7 in a lot of
ways it really will and I think you're
going to see a sense of urgency from
both teams I think you're going to see a
high level intensely fought battle
tonight both because I think Golden
State and I think they thought so coming
in they understood that Houston is
capable of beating them and that's a
healthy respect to have for an opponent
and now he's in a position where they
can in some ways put go
an enviable position of having a face at
an elimination game a couple more
minutes left here with Greg Anthony of
Turner Sports there's many ways I could
ask this question based on game five in
the Eastern Conference Finals but I'm
just gonna go stroll I'm just gonna go
straight simple what's up with the Cavs
what's up with them that roster outside
LeBron is not very confident they play
nervous they know it's weird they played
like they play like Boston plays on the
road the difference is often has an
excuse they don't have a superstar and
they're young you know I expect boss
struggle on the road as they have the
entire postseason I'm just shocked and
again I credit a lot of this to Boston
because they're very physical and
they're very athletic across the board
and that does tend to wear on a team
that is you know jealous no sir not as
quickly got let it as it used to be
yours Hill isn't as quick or athletic
call corner Kevin Love is you know and
so it's they're able to negate and
nullify a lot of execution of Cleveland
because they can be physical and when
your physical defensively you can
disrupt time to the space and that's why
you're saying it good
you know forget the rest of this
important guys how about look at the
turnovers LeBrons averages in series
he's having a sixth turn always a game
and and that tells you right there that
they're having no effect on what they
want to do they're just quicker to the
ball that was physical they're more
active and they're even more so at home
and so now the question is if you're
Cleveland can you force that that game
seven back in in Boston and hope that
LeBron can have one of those games
because unless I mean even Kevin Love
last night look like a role player like
you know that that's that's basically
what it ball down to the ground was you
could still argue the best but the next
five best player it's played to Boston
and if that continues Boston's gonna win
the series
no doubt about it yes Cleveland's in a
world of trouble yeah I mean it doesn't
look like Batman's got a Robin it's just
a bunch of Alfred's being honest with
you out there you got any Alfred's you
could you know alpha to give you a
chance you know
how does it happen where the wrapped I
mean if I'm a raptor fan I'm like that's
the team that swept us I'm you gotta be
cute
in a weird way Boston doesn't have a
psychological baggage baggage that
Toronto has and quite frankly they don't
have the foster you know like look look
they've got multiple guys that are going
to compete defensively and their help
defense and their overall defense is
better than rocks and then the other
thing they've done is they at home
especially they have shot lights out for
three so you think about Marcus Morris
physically in compete can guard multiple
positions
Marcus large in the ground I mean Terry
Rozier at bat you know Jason Tatum those
guys compete and Baynes has been
terrific for them it gets good
especially at home so you know they got
so many different ways to combat you I
think
Cleveland's only averaging about 85
points a game on the road this is and so
forth offensive minded teams they have
no shot if they can't get close to a
hundred because defensively I don't
think they're going to be able to
completely stop what Boston does the
only question is one can they win
tomorrow night and - can it Boston
doesn't shoot the three well that's the
thing I look at I look at turnovers and
three-point shots and Game seven if it
gets there because Boston's gonna have
some confidence right now it looks like
Cleveland is a little bit shaken LeBron
and a lot of times when you everyone's
talking about him fatigue I think he was
I think he was a little more demoralized
to with the fact that he wasn't getting
any help from anybody on that roster and
then that that should make Adelaide one
decision even more interesting when it
all said and done Greg oh yeah
appreciate the time Greg enjoy the game
tonight we'll chat with you during the
NBA Finals that's Greg Anthony 50 on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience